North Carolina's new bathroom bill isn't
just about where you can pee it's one of
the most wide-reaching anti-lgbt bills
in the country and it's got a lot of
people worried basically the law says
transgender people must use the bathroom
that corresponds to the biological sex
listed on their birth certificate not
their gender identity supporters of the
law say it's protecting women by
preventing predators from claiming to be
transgender in order to access women's
restrooms but there's a big problem with
this reasoning there are no documented
cases of it happening but there are
plenty of documented cases of violence
against transgender women who are at
risk when forced to use the men's
bathroom this law which was quickly
signed in an emergency session also
undoes all the LGBT anti-discrimination
policies passed by cities in the state
that means that cities that had
anti-discrimination laws like those
about jobs and housing can no longer
enforce them now North Carolina is just
one of many states with a negative track
record when it comes to protecting
gender identity in 2015 alone 21 laws
limiting transgender rights were passed
in the US and in the first three months
of this year 44 more were introduced in
addition to policing bathrooms these
laws keep people from getting IDs that
match their gender identity and
transgender prisoners from getting
transition-related drugs but as any of
this constitutional opponents say no and
a federal lawsuit has already been
brought against North Carolina saying
the new law violates the Fourteenth
Amendment because it singles out LGBT
people for discrimination and North
Carolina's Attorney General says he
won't defend the new law in court
businesses have also spoken out against
the law including companies with a big
presence in North Carolina like PayPal
Bank of America and Dow Chemical even
the NBA has said this could cost the
state a chance to host an all-star game
that's a big deal for a state where
basketball comes second only to religion
one big question remains how will they
even enforce the new law